these are the people who stand on the
grave of Martin Luther King jr. once a
year every year and try to use his words
for political expediency and it's just
not accurate I think that if he had been
anywhere close to what we have today his
speech might have been a little
different question of the day what do
you think given the information Martin
Luther King would have thought of the
modern social justice movement that
includes everything entered gender as
MLG btq AIP black lives matter just I
don't even know if black life matters -
laughs Ana they called something else I
don't think so I have no idea but let's
imagine Martin Luther King jr. today I'd
like to contrast his words his ideas
with the ideas of the left who of course
left the day if I Martin Luther King jr.
um today and by the way before I go on I
I get before you get into the comments
section I understand it's important to
separate the ideology the ideas the isms
from the man hey I get it he was flawed
serial philandering plagiarist might
have done crack but that's not what
we're talking about who among us throw
the first crack stone this is a rock but
I want to focus on the ideas that he
espoused and not only espoused but
actively encouraged I mean this was his
Hays on that this is what he lived for
so let's contrast at first Martin Luther
King jr. where would you think that he
lines up on Western civilization
particularly the United States of
America well he was very much
passionately pro-constitution
pro-western judeo-christian morality and
a lot of you'll forget this he was a
pastor right
often referred some Reverend pastor not
entirely sure the difference I think
it's a caller
sometimes a pointy hat but he supported
these ideas particularly of the founders
and the Declaration of Independence and
our Constitution it was a common theme
in his speeches
but one day this nation will rise up
live out the true meaning of its free we
hold these truths to be self-evident
that all men are created
isn't it funny that when you go back and
look at that you know the audience was
mixed but the black people if they were
to dress that way today would be accused
of not being black and yeah sure you
brought him in and by the way he
expanded on that even further there was
I want to bring this up a letter from
Birmingham jail where he wrote one day
the south will know that when these
disinherited children of God sat down at
lunch counters they were in reality
standing up for what is best in the
American dream and for the most sacred
values in our judeo-christian heritage
and thusly carrying our nation back to
those great wells of democracy which
were dug deep by the founding fathers in
their formulation of the Constitution
and the Declaration of Independence he
had all the notes you couldn't find that
at an NRA convention nope independence
constitution founding fathers basically
evil white guys you seemed like he was a
fan yep because he was a fan of the
ideas regardless of who espoused them
that's an important part of his
worldview let's contrast that with
today's progressive leftist they see
themselves as fighting against the ideas
of the founding fathers I've got a
simple idea let's give up on the
Constitution I know it sounds radical
but it's really not I just expect that
guy to go and then to make a crappy
redux with Benicio del Toro and Anthony
Hopkins didn't work didn't work yikes
it was at you know werewolves were
ruined by that fruitcake in Twilight
they're no longer scary let's go to
Martin Luther King jr. and the LGBTQA
AIP agenda here's something that's
important it's not only was he not on
board with it okay he actively rallied
in
spoke against it now I'm not I'm not
saying that I agree with everything MLK
jr. spoke to okay but I want you to be
clear on what it is that he believed
writing it advice an advice column in
Ebony magazine is that so a magazine
evany yeah I just thought it was stuff
what that's an actual magazine out of
touch people here are with black
cultures yes I am I believe is an
African imagine is always big butts it's
like stuff magazine let's bring this up
not on any of the covers I am NOT but I
said I cut it a wide swath okay every
magazine he was asked the following this
was a question from young man my problem
is different from the ones most people
have I am a boy but I feel about boys
the way I ought to feel about girls I
don't want my parents to know about me
what can I do
is there any place where I can go for
help and you know what listen you go
back contextually that's kind of a sad
letter to read someone who feels like
they can't actually be comfortable in
their own skin here's the response from
dr. Reverend pastor Martin Luther King
jr. I don't think you were the caller
your problem is not at all an uncommon
one however it does require careful
attention the type of feeling that you
have towards boys is probably not an
innate tendency but something that has
been culturally acquired your reasons
for adopting this habit oh habit like
it's smoking cigarettes have now been
consciously suppressed or unconsciously
repressed therefore it is necessary to
deal with this problem by getting back
to some of the experiences and
circumstances that lead to this habit in
order to do this I would suggest that
you see a good psychiatrist holy shmow
can who can assist you in bringing to
the forefront of conscience all of those
experiences and circumstances that led
to the habit you are already on the
right road toward a solution since you
honestly recognize the problem and have
a desire to solve it he was one step
away from Mike Pence tipping people into
shock therapy like shutter island' so
contrary by the way to this that this
comparison made between civil
rights which existed historically and
the modern LGBTQA AIP movement Reverend
dr. King he believed that there was a
difference between discrimination based
on one's inherent skin color and the
plight of those who prefer different
sexual friction a black man being this
is what this saw a black man being hose
down at a diner used as a German
shepherds shits entraining toy may not
be comparable to this guy's plight not
being allowed to take a dump in a little
girl's room I think it's important to
notice that there's a little bit of a
difference on the one hand right we have
leftist they today they see gender
sexuality race everything else is being
inextricably linked right through this
idea of intersectionality
intersectionality refers to the reality
that we all have multiple identities
that intersect to make us who we are it
also gives us a way to talk about
oppressions and privileges that overlap
and reinforce each other this term dates
back to the 1980s and legal scholar
kimberlé crenshaw okay
this is why I left us believe that you
can't be against racism without pushing
every other agenda up and including the
radical transit it so it's all part of
one package with them one tiny inverted
duct-tape package I want to make sure
that just we understand because this is
the jumping-off point and people invoke
the name of Martin Luther King jr. and
they make films about him but they gloss
over the truth as to what he stood for
and I know some of you may say it was
that point in time right if you were
alive today he would have a different
viewpoint
maybe but here's the thing back then
there were still people who were
Democrats but progressive leftists who
were still pushing these kinds of ideas
right you can go back to boomers you can
see what people believed in the hippy
the flower power area you can see what
people believed as far as wealth
distribution in radical socialism you
can see what they believed in inherent
patriarchal Christian society and how
they wanted to destroy that foundation
he saw that and spoke out against it he
wasn't a Republican country to popular
belief I'm not gonna perpetuate that
myth but he wasn't really a Democrat
either he was a man of principle as he
saw it and you try to gloss over the
ones that you don't like by the way hit
the notification bell and hit all
notifications
if you're subscribed on YouTube because
apparently what is it all notification
you gotta hit oh you guys subscribe you
got to talk touch the bell the Bell will
open you say tall you say tuck well the
dirty and slow me off yet he will do the
tuck I prefer the helicopter top it's a
party trick my wife loves it and of
course join my club letters got it
becomes less my club that's what allows
us to continue this is something else
that's really important obviously I
think many of you know this but you may
notice in the context Martin Luther King
jr. and his views on how you affect
change in society society notably his
support for peaceful protest let me say
as I've always said and I will always
continue to say that riots are socially
destructive and self-defeating I'm still
convinced that non-violence is the most
potent weapon available to oppress
people in their struggle for freedom and
justice I feel that violence will only
create more social problems than they
will fall I understand what people say
he was a good speaker Lee I'm watching
that I'm going I wish I were black now
you know I'm kind of ashamed that I'm
not I feel like there's a party that
I've been left out and there's like a
house party and there's a guy I look
through the window there's a guy in
there with the disappointing and I think
this is important because a lot of
people assume that all figureheads of
most social movements believe this not
if you contrast it to people like
Malcolm X or even people all around like
Farrakhan not all Black Liberation
Theology believed in in peaceful protest
that's important was he was going
against the grain right compared to a
lot of people you can look at the Black
Panthers you can look at some of the
other leaders that's important to
recognize and I think it's important not
to gloss over because it is one of the
facets that makes Martin Luther King jr.
unique and why he's beloved by white and
black people alike he believed in a
non-violent legislative process now
let's contrast that with again today's
progressives
violence has become not only common at
leftist protests over the last decade of
course that we did a video on a black
lives matter video still up on YouTube
or do we have to take it down it may be
down and if the I'm not entirely sure a
lot of them are down but if it's a if
it's down you can go to mug club started
with that you know you go back to black
lives matter and you fast-forward you
have an to feel you have Occupy Wall
Street any time leftists have gathered
in the last two decades let's go three
decades you can even go to Woodstock or
Woodstock 99 either was wood and stock
in it all the way up to an tyfa today
violence isn't an exception it tends to
be the rule
don't you love that girl who loves the
protection of knowing that a man won't
hit her right dude
[Applause]
she gets my blood boiling even watching
this I just hate that so much
[Applause]
how long in this clip there's ten more
second to this
Oh
[Applause]
the worst part is he's Asian let me
float up a tree branch and flutter kick
yeah what happened he was working on a
Jackie Chan's full of crap man let's do
a little thought experiment because this
is what really bothers me you have some
people who say well you know the Wrights
been hijacked by the far right and you
know the left is a pretty most people
are in the middle and you have some
radical leftist you hear this a lot like
people talk about the social justice
left and the antifreeze speak but that's
not a big percentage of straw bedding
okay Martin Luther King jr. all right
let's put them side by he's column a
column B is every single one of the
currently left I think 1900 candidates
for the DNC on a national platform where
do you think they would agree all right
LGBTQ AIP agenda no ok the importance of
family being the central building block
of Western society nope okay the
Constitution the founding fathers the
first amendment the second amendment
nope okay how about the idea of equal
rights and viewing people on the
continent you don't seeing them through
the content of the character rather than
the color of their skin nope that goes
against intersectionality that goes
against identity name me one issue where
Martin Luther King jr. and Debbie
wasserman-schultz or Elizabeth Warren or
Bernie Sanders or I Cory Booker's n
Annie who's in him what would take your
pick one where they would line up one
where Martin Luther King jr. would say
that's my pick let alone the roster at
MSNBC or CNN or Think Progress you tell
what is it they might support a slightly
higher tax is that it by the way
slightly higher tax meant a little bit
of a different thing even if Martin
Luther King jr. supported it compared
with Bernie Sanders 92 percent would be
a good thing so again you can't even get
into economics and say they would line
up something else I think is pretty
important again because this is why we
praised Martin Luther King jr. but it's
not what today's left wants where he
stood and how he espoused and really
communicated effectively this is why he
was so inspiring the idea of focusing
and aiming to achieve unity versus
division
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
that almost sounds like he's really
taking his responsibilities seriously as
a dad hmm so what King jr. I should say
King jr. thingy King was the guy who
kneeled no no we're still on Martin
Luther King jr. stay with me okay jr. Oh
more recent he wanted Americans to be
united okay fine
wanted to be united under what under
race under economic justice no he wanted
us to be united by ideas and values as
opposed to being divided by race and
back then yeah there were some white
people terrible white people who still
wanted to divide people by race that
switched a little bit today sometimes
but what ideas under which do you want
to see us unified those espoused by the
Constitution and Declaration of
Independence the according to him exact
words judeo-christian ideas that founded
Western society he believed most
important above all was not race was not
sex or gender when sex is no longer a
thing but we need to share the values
and if you think you need to fill in the
blanks he filled in the blanks very
clearly as to what those values were
again compare it with any modern DNC
candidate or leftist journalist send me
your comments what do leftists want they
want people to be and I'm speaking in
some generalities of course because I
have to save time but again I think it's
pretty fair if we use the entire DNC
roster it's a fair generalization when
they all think pretty much the same
except one believes in a slightly higher
tax bracket and the other believes in an
astronomically higher tax rate the left
wants to have people viewed exclusively
through the prism of race sex when that
doesn't work gender make one up make up
54 if you want white privilege male
privilege they want to identify people
which is funny to me because we're not
allowed to according to the leftist
rules make jokes about intrinsic
characteristics right they don't want us
to make jokes about
race jokes about sex jokes about gender
jokes about cultural differences but
they want you to recognize people
exclusively they want you to put them in
your filing cabinet in your manila
folder and categorize them exclusively
by race gender sex there you go you know
what why would you become familiar with
the phrase you hear it on the show a lot
it's somewhat of a cultural flashpoint
certainly during the Trump era about
race class politics as sure they're all
intensifying so it is in that
environment that comedian Chelsea
Handler comes to the show tonight what
surprised you most the inability of for
white people to admit to admit to white
privilege because what I think I've
discovered and I think I read a line
somewhere that says that said equality
to those who have had it feels like a
loss so like if you admit that you are a
beneficiary of white privilege that
means to a lot of people I have to start
sacrificing things and I have to give
something up okay couple of things do
you think I exaggerate they actually the
left is they've actually made up
worksheets to calculate your exact
amount of privilege that's how serious
they are about it but she just said you
know it feels like a loss and so people
you you might have to give up something
I understand that at some point I
understand it in 1964 right where there
wasn't equality if you're looking before
the Civil Rights Act the Voting Act I
understand that perhaps just some
racists who met on the weekend with
hoods horrible people understood right
let's make sure that we condemn them at
our event roundly I understand they
maybe thought it was a lost but in I
don't want to say 2020 or 2019 because
I'd kind of be cutting my argument short
here a little bit the last four decades
where we've had equal rights what do we
need to give up this is something I
don't know when Chelsea Handler's it
means you might have to give up
something okay
so let's just go with 2020 to simplify
it for you Chelsea because I understand
you read a line somewhere at once as you
said on Chris Cuomo are you Ted I'm
Chris Cuomo sure I should say what what
do I need to give up what do white
people as a group need to give up and
how would that improve black lives what
do we do we need to give up even lower
expectations on SAT scores
even more quotas in job placement in a
college what what could white people or
males for talking or straight people sis
people what could they give up in 2020
that would help the supposedly oppressed
minorities the point is there's no when
everything is equal which is what we
have now there's no longer anything to
give up you're just trying to now create
in inequality to right the wrongs of the
past and that was a worldview that
Martin Luther King jr. if you read his
writings beyond a line somewhere at some
point Chelsea that you would see he
clearly advocated against does it sound
reductive good that's because it is
because these are the people who stand
on the grave of Martin Luther King jr.
once a year every year and try to use
his words for political expediency and
it's just not accurate and it's one of
those things it just shows you how much
the media has been carrying the water of
the left because all that would be
required to debunk it is for people to
listen to the whole speech to read
writing from MLK Jr any writing read any
of his advice columns read any of his
dissertation some of the hopefully
drives I know we're not so about the man
but the point is the values any of it
and you would go oh of course these
people have no idea what he was about a
lot of people do ask if and we have to
have to wrap up if MLK jr. if he were
alive did it would he be a Democrat I
you know I let me know what you think I
think that if he had been anywhere close
to what we have today his speech might
have been a little different
[Applause]
man woman Dior your guess is as good as
mine will be seen only as a some parts
of the sexual organs skin car and all
results of their current hormone
replacement therapy I have a dream I
have a dream that a man will not be
admitted to college based on the quality
of his test scores or performance but by
a purely race based bell curve and that
one day not a single Chairman faithful
in the hallway
hey if you liked this video be sure to
subscribe if you're already subscribed
hit the notification bell hit all
notifications we have new videos that go
up every day as well as of course an
entire show not available on YouTube at
ladder with credit comm slash mug Club
if you did not like this show please
comment below and address your comments
to Gerald
be sure to do that also his Twitter